can government agencies seize a person
cryptocurrency by forcing coinbase
to to hand it over
so when you're centralized you they have
a phone number to call
okay so this is a complicated topic um
like if you really want to be sure that
um this is why people want to store
their own crypto right like with
self-custodial wallets like with
coinbase wallet and bracing
decentralization they want to avoid that
now in the u.s there is rule of law
right so we have reasonable protections
in place around
um like search and seizure and things
like that
um you know coinbase does we publish
transparency reports on this we get
subpoenas court orders things like that
from various
um countries around the world
and
there are situations where we have been
ordered to freeze accounts things like
that
you know we have to follow the law is
there's no another way to put it we're a
regulated financial service business and
so
if the money is used to break as part of
breaking the law that's what that uh in
a particular
jurisdiction in particular
right and then the other thing sometimes
you we will actually get court orders or
subpoenas that are overly broad we've
seen so they need to follow
due process right and so
we've seen um some in the past that were
like
well we need you to freeze this huge
number of accounts and it's like well
we'll actually gone to court and like
pushed back on some of these and said
like what is your
the probable cause and is that has the
threshold been met and like we've won
some of those cases on behalf of our
customers so
yeah it's it's actually really
it's kind of unfortunate and frustrating
as a you know as a large business you
spend a lot of resources basically
interacting with um
inbound requests by all kinds of lawyers
and people and
requesting things and some of them are
silly and ridiculous and you have to
push back and say no and so
um it's kind of a tax on every company
at a certain size which ultimately gets
passed on to the the customer in higher
fees so
you have to employ armies of lawyers to
deal with this stuff can you educate me
on something how much innovation
is there in the legal space
so for lawyers working with coinbase
because it's such a new
cutting-edge thing
so you're
if there's a lot of gray area you're
supposed to be operating
under like how hard is is it being a
lawyer at coinbase
like uh how much precedence is there i
guess is what i'm asking i mean just
like you said three years
it's kind of a new space yeah well it's
probably very hard to be coinbase and
very fun because
you know whenever you're in a new field
that's growing fast there isn't a lot of
um
case law and just precedent set so
that's also an opportunity for you to go
create that stuff and that's what a lot
of legal careers are made out of is like
take a complex situation where you have
to balance difficult things like how do
we prevent bad activity but still enable
an innovation that's a hard question
and there's you can go draft legislation
and circulate at the policy makers or
come up with these policies and
you know how do you operate a business
in an environment where the law is just
unclear right it's like try to do the
right thing
um but like
you know strike the right balance so
yeah a lot of our lawyers have to come
up with that very creative stuff
you